c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
tous les gens du comité mais le
community community manager d'art car je
suis du sud vient toulouse donc c'est
une tradition gto cantine toute ma
jeunesse et il était obligatoire de
faire une partie de pétanque e à la fin
d' agents du passé mais gare à ce round
du psg donc c'est ya rien pire que l'om
tout - d'arc a cédé série que j'adore
par exemple orphan black ou mind hunter
qui est formidable et que je conseille à
tous fast food
alors ça dépend c'est plutôt d'astra qui
veut dire les deux puisque j'ai bien
compris
alors parce que moi j'aime bien five
guys parce que c'est du fast food mais
un peu ils veulent donc la viande a les
bonnes et frites elles ont des goûts de
patates et c'est pas trop standardisée
donc voilà ça dépend je vais dire ça
sera et parce que je trouve qu'il est
trop long de bois illyriens et on a
envie un peu de foot avec je sais pas d
arguments de la fièvre du tempérament et
là je trouve que c'est que on à l'invs
recensé des éléments de langage des
hommes politiques
elle est à toi je trouve que c'est méga
sera c'est complètement ringard alors je
sais que tous les footeux en ont tous
les hommes un peu digne de ce nom comme
les beckham est tous à son nom sont
tatoués c'est bien quand on est jeune
mais à mon âge c'est complètement
ringard et après on dit mais pourquoi on
a fait ça quand on était jeune donc
voilà on va nous être laissés d'arca
voilà en plus ça non alors c'est
d'arkham et c'est aussi un peu ras sera
donc c'est d'asra est-ce que comment on
peut pas filmer ça sent la transpiration
donc ça c'est un vrai problème donc
c'est bien là
denis mai
[Musique]